We present a wearable,
motion capture system
that can acquire
emotions of an individual
almost anywhere over
extended periods of time.
Our system consists of an array
of small, low-cost, low-power
sensors placed on
the body of a person.
The system is
completely autonomous.
It does not require any external
devices or signal sources.
In this prototype, we use eight
signal sources and 18 signal
detectors as our
sensors, our sources
are small, ultrasonic
transducers
that sequentially emit pulses
about 16 times a second each.
We use small microphones
as signal detectors
for the ultrasonic pulses.
The detectors also contain
three-axis accelerometers
and three-axis gyroscopes
that sample accelerations
and angular velocities
about 140 times per second,
significantly improving the
precision and the frame rate
of the ultrasonic measurements.
Using the onboard
microprocessor,
the accelerometer
and gyro values
are digitally
encoded and combined
with the analog audio
signal from the microphones.
All signal sources and detectors
are wired to the driver box.
The driver box consists of
the following components--
18 second-stage amplifiers
that further amplify the signal
from each of the sensors, 3
six-channel, analog-to-digital
converters that sample
the signal from 18 sensors
at 150 kilosamples per
second, a microcontroller that
synchronizes all HD
converters and generates pulse
signals for the
ultrasonic transducers.
The signal from
the microcontroller
to the transducers
is then amplified
by the transducer drivers.
The driver box is powered by
a small, rechargeable battery
pack that lasts for
more than four hours.
The data from all
A-to-D converters
is transmitted using
a USB 2.0 connection
to a laptop which records
this data directly
to its hard drive.
The driver box and laptop can
be carried in a small backpack.
Our prototype system was built
from off-the-shelf components
for less than $3,000.
Here is a comparison
between our reconstruction
and that of the
Vicon optical system.
In this sequence,
distance measurements
prevent drift in
the left shoulder.
The mobility of
our system allows
us to capture motion virtually
anywhere, for example,
while driving a car.
We were able to track all
limbs as well as recover more
detailed and subtle motions.
Even motions that are
traditionally hard to acquire
are captured with
ease using our system.